globalement imaginer à peu près cinq
fois plus de personnes surtout à la
proche du mur des je t'aime montmartre
quartier d'ordinaire très fréquenté par
les touristes
dans ce square parfois on est obligé de
lui faire du coude à coude parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de monde et il ya des
embouteillages de groupes touristiques
cette guide habite et travaille à
montmartre un village sans ses visiteurs
habituels même pas au pied de sa célèbre
base il est là il n'y a pas beaucoup
mais là il reste les privilégiés ceux
qui profitent de montmartre dans ces
circonstances une étonnante
la france est toujours inaccessible aux
américains et aux chinois notamment des
millions de visiteurs en moins
certains hôtels n'ont même pas ouvert
leurs portes regardez-la des chaînes de
vent sur la porte d'entrée
c'est bien révélateur de ce qu'on est en
train de vivre une véritable crise
frappe tous ces parisiens qui vivent du
tourisme
c'est très calme très calme ce midi ce
restaurateur a reçu cinq fois moins de
clients qu'un jour ordinaire
on est resté ouvert cette semaine pour
voir comment ça se passait mais nos
confrères aux alentours y en a beaucoup
qui n'ont pas ouvert
d'autres qui atteindront septembre un
peu partout dans montmartre ce sentiment
que les dés sur un long et pas très
rentable s'il y a un signe d'espoir dans
tout ça c'est que les grandes têtes
d'affiché du tourisme parisien
recommence à accueillir des visiteurs
[Musique]
réouverture en grande pompe pour la dame
de fer comme un rappel foyer ou
touristes un peu partout les premiers à
s'y présenter son français là on a que
comme ça je pense que ça sera pas de
sitôt
on a vraiment de la chance et on est
vraiment content d'être là ya pas encore
trop demandant le précepte au village
d'été premier donc
cet été la dame de fer ne pourra
accueillir beaucoup de visiteurs en
raison des strictes mesures d'hygiène
les responsables misent sur le tourisme
local
comme ce parisien qui se trouve là haut
pour la première fois de sa vie
je suis comme un gosse de 10 en cinq ans
je suis là je pouvais plus tard qu'est
ce que c'est beau et c'est bien de se
réapproprier sa ville aussi les français
savent qu'ils sont privilégiés cet été
ils savent aussi que la reprise
économique dépend en partie du retour
des étrangers ici il ya un an et dûment
baron radio-canada paris